hey everybody and welcome to this ulta
edge full unboxing video um this isn't
going to be the full uh the review video
of any of the products in this package
but all of them are in the title and
their link is in the description so
please go check that out and um what i'm
going to do today is just unbox the
products and uh just i pardoned that the
fact that this box is so big it did not
fit in the entire picture it's not even
widescreen i don't think but i'm
basically i'm going to open this box up
for you guys
so without any further delay here we go
um there's i don't think the products in
here are
quite as big as this box is and i'll try
to get the box out of the view as soon
as we're done opening this so here we go
i'm trying to get this tape off here
this did ship ups and it came in about
two days shipping from the same state
than i am in so that was very good
so here we go if i can get this open
i'll probably edit this part out uh
actually i might not i'll just open this
for you guys here
so as we open this up here we have a lot
of paper i know it's hard for these
cars you guys to see
but this is their desktop microphone
um so here we go i can pretty much take
this off the desk but here is their
yeah
so here is their gooseneck desktop
microphone uh this is uh the gn3 again
the link is in the description if you
want to look more about this product i'm
just going to unbox the uh the actual uh
product for you guys here now this is
the gooseneck soundtech microphone and
this is actually here you go i'll show
you this is what it looks like this is
what it'll look like on your desk a
flexible standard looks like so here we
go um
i'll probably cut this front part open
here
and get to the plastic
and like i said i won't be using noise
cancellation for the background noise in
these videos because it kind of distorts
it
because of the voice so here we go
um so here's the gooseneck uh microphone
and what we're gonna do is look area so
this packaging is pretty good actually
there's actually uh what this is a
magnetic front to it so i'll just pull
it up and it's very soft and velvety on
the top which is very cool
and we pull resolve it up and here we go
first thing that we see in the front is
the microphone itself okay so um this is
the uh the form that they give you to
put on top obviously but this is um well
here we go first of all here's the
gooseneck
so this is the microphone itself uh the
gooseneck looks like it actually looks
pretty good i'm fitting in the in the
camera right here uh the the whole pivot
joint is right here uh looks like it's
made of very very nice metal and another
pivot joint is at the top
and um
the uh
the plug to plug it into your computer
is right here so this end right here
will plug into this end which will plug
into my computer's microphone jack so
that's very cool
and here is the stand for the
professional microphone it's quite heavy
i'll have you know and again you can
plug it right into there and this will
plug into your uh computer oh so it's a
very cool system so the desktop the
gooseneck will plug into
this or will plug into the base which
will plug into your computer via this so
that's very cool and the great thing
that they do is that they do give you
two uh little foam things to protect it
and to keep it sound um basically
sounding pretty good so that is the
unboxing video there's nothing else in
this box i can tell it is quite heavy
but that's just the unboxing i will
definitely get you guys a great review
and i will be using it for my tutorials
you guys will be able to hear what this
sounds like so again check out ulta
edges link in the description very very
nice product and i can't really i really
can't wait to get started using this
thing so thanks for watching the
unboxing video and again there are more
hardware and software videos to come if
you like what you saw here hit the
subscribe button and um please enjoy
peace